pitching definitely the order today of
course in this ballpark for this first
week it seems to be the case every day
but today should be kind of special and
for our own lance lynn a big day for him
a chance to go for another big win to
tell martay the switch hitter steps in
he was two for five yesterday he's hit
safely in all five d-backs games he's
hitting 333.
there's a punch-out to start the game
slow back to the dugout two away and
here is escobar swung on and missed he's
struck and now it got the fastball up to
96. so two punch-outs for lance lim
lefty madison bumgarner and yes a loss
in san diego in the opener but as matt
her just said yesterday really just 102
pitch away from six scoreless sittings
against the padres that's hit in the air
down the right field line angling back
toward the corner is calhoun
and up against the wall he makes the
catch right under the 326 side and elvis
going after the first pitch has flied
out to calhoun in the right field corner
door will go to first with two outs for
joey gallo and gallow takes a breaking
pitch in there for strike three first
strikeout for bumgarner expands the
problem
to tell martay seven for 22
to start 2020. martay takes and now
takes his base lead off walked carson
kelly a single from john jay made it
first and third a walk to catel marte
cole calhoun digs in
1-2 to calhoun
big strikeout all right giddy up
lancelin eduardo escobar base is loaded
two out here in the third glenn fires
the 2-2 there's a ball slapped into left
field garcia on the move toward the line
he gets there to make the running grab
no runs a hit the bases are left loaded
yeah we mentioned his numbers against
bumgarner i think the curve ball that
bum gardner likes to throw to the back
foot is a pitch that frazier can hit out
one-handed two-and-two to fraser frazier
hits it well again this one does get
into the seats
todd frazier with a solo home run
to put the rangers on the board remember
we talked about i like this match-up
frazier and garcia on one water
right-handed hitters who'd like to hit
the ball out front that's his game todd
frazier is connor falefa he'll be at
third with one out of the ending now for
the number nine hitter for bumgarner
trevino doubles the texas ranger lead
now two nothing hey trevino jumping on
the off speed pitch from the lefty
rangers take advantage of your first
opportunity with a man in scoring
position two quick outs for escobar
zofra two a strikeout on the ladder to
left when he swings and pops one out
left side
connor falletha
waving his arms makes the catch what a
job by lance lynn when six scoreless
innings went one two three and five of
the innings loaded the bases in the
third he gave up one hit two watts and
that was it there's carson kelly
kelly gets the bound on the baseball
that drops in to center field
one run scores
peralta held up the third deficit cut in
half for arizona
now jay who was one for two against
lance lynn will be there first pitch
swinging for john jay
garcia
now off the arm
the
situational hitting
kelly
and jay get it done
yahoo no for three today and in the
series he's over seven
now whether calhoun was saying that ball
clipped his foot or not
yeah he i think he was asking the dugout
hey guys what do you got on that because
i felt something
all you can do is ask
oh
take your base
take your base
so one out base runner for eduardo
escobar
oh descended into the gap in right
center field the castro has wheels it
gets to the wall
easily scoring is the castro the d-backs
have the lead thanks to a triple from
eduardo escobar so first and third now
the banner will beat peralta
peralta lifts it into left field garcia
going back makes the great escobar
tagging
escobar scores and it's four to arizona
gallow up is a time run here we go
gallow out
to left center field did you
joey gallow ties the game with a 2-1
home run his second home run of the
season both have come off of lefties and
yes joey can hit a mere mortal home run
so here we go fraser at third counter
paleta at second trevino at first and
elvis andrews steps in
the middle
elvis gives the rangers the lead two-run
score
6-4
now nick solo
mixola
will dump one into right field the ghost
sign's been given
7-4
texas
coaching staff smile look back on this
thing and say maybe that gets his jump
started
and it'll be none other than joey gallo
with the bases loaded
[Applause]
[Applause]
major league save
shot back to the mound good at first
in a big
needed comeback win for the texas
rangers 7 for the final